thanks a lot so here's again the title
of my talk and I'd like to acknowledge
my main collaborators for this research
this is Jonas taters from Copenhagen
Nick why mind how to my colleague and
Dominick rotten how is the release now
here in Berkeley in fact he was a key
contributor of what I do present today
so if you look at this title you might
ask well what do these things have to do
with each other and I start with
causality and robustness and we have
been working on the former a rather
exotic problem for quite a while
but it turns out that there are
interesting connections to robustness
and this is what I want to explain a bit
here today so here is a nutshell view of
robust optimization distributionally
robust optimization so you have a loss
function you have data random variable
Steve are X and YX Arco here it's why
our response variables I have an unknown
parameter beta I look at the risk P is
kind of a distribution the data
generating distribution maybe and I look
at worst case rediscover a class and try
to find the parameter which optimizes
that worst case really so typically the
class of distributions is within a
master's time distance for this radius
Rho around p0 around the reference and
p0 might be the empirical distribution
so this has good performance under
adversarial distributions and in my view
one important point here is that it is
also good under adversarial test
distribution so but it happens in the
test sample might be quite different in
what you've seen in the data this is
quite a bit different from maybe the
more classical robust statistics point
of view so this is celebrated minimax
results so you can look at robust
statistics from a worst-case risk
optimization point of view so it looks
exactly kind of similar so we have a
risk and l2 risk you look at worst-case
risk and you find you try to find
debased estimator in fact in a certain
class this is the hubris demeanor is a
different loss function
so the class is typically a neighborhood
of a Gaussian reference distribution p0
we've heard about this a bit yesterday
and a bit philosophically a main
difference in my view is that this is
particularly geared for good performance
under contaminated training sample
distribution maybe also in the taste
sample but already the training sample
is contaminated okay so here is maybe a
more general robustness viewpoint and
what we aim to do is to achieve
stability or we call it and also near
invariance as you will see later for a
class of meaningful or interesting
distributions and this class is not
necessarily a neighborhood it's not
necessarily say a a ball this have a
certain metric or anything like that but
we try to capture our interesting
directions for which we want to achieve
stability or robustness wow this is a
bit like in classical statistical
robustness it's also like in robust
optimization but perhaps surprisingly
also causality can be looked at from
this viewpoint you want to look at the
class of distributions where you are
stable so now I say quite a few things
on causality and then coming back to
robustness but that's kind of my
motivation that the things are actually
closely connected with each other
well causality avert call is super
ambitious it is perhaps too ambitious
for many practical problems but our
point is in a way even if it is too
ambitious at least in some applications
we want to do something which is perhaps
more suitable than things which you then
add technique which is based under
standard regression of classification
frame even if you cannot find the causes
and maybe this is you know what life is
it's very very hard to find the causes
maybe we can do something better than
just standard regression or
classification the gold standard in
causality would be a randomized control
experiment that's great two dudes is
very difficult very costly can be
unethical and so on so forth and very
modern applications
do not have access to randomized control
trial data and so my question is what
can we say if we do not have access to
data from around mind control shop my
point will be an attractive phrase it
more as a burst case optimization
problem we look at this from a
prediction point of view now causality
is actually some sort of predictive
question the question in causality in a
loosened actually could be formulated as
it is a what if I do question or a
question what would happen if I perturb
that's kind of the central question in
causality and so the point here is I'd
try to do a prediction scheme for the
outcome of an unobserved manipulation of
an unobserved perturbation of an
unobserved intervention okay so many
modern applications are faced with these
kind of questions so in genomics this is
theorem personally been involved in the
question could read as follows what
would be the effect if you manipulate a
certain gene in a plant this is a
picture of the Arab adopts this plant
and I'm interested in the effect on the
growth rate of the plant
okay so you would like to know what
would happen if you manipulate gene
seven but you do not have data from this
perturbation of gene said what if you
want to predict this manipulation but
you have no data on that perturbation or
you need commerce it would be the
question what would be the effect of
showing a person XYZ an advertisement
and social media but you have no data on
such an advertisement campaign of such
an intervention of a person X Y Z or
person being similar in X Y Z and so on
and so forth so modern applications are
full with these kind of questions and so
here's a very simple slide but I think
it's instructive and it's kind of
interesting to look at suppose you have
two variables x and y y is my outcome I
have X a covariant it is actually
synthetic data just to warm up a bit and
of course you see this data you say okay
I can fit a straight line this is great
this is easy to do in a regression
course rotate it fits quite well
and now the question is okay now I
manipulate on X I make a perturbation on
X this is what I have to observed in the
data I manipulate and I say I put the
value of the covariant X to say minus 8
and the question is what would be the
best prediction for Y if you believe in
regression technology your prediction is
here on the line that would be the best
prediction and that of course
corresponds to somehow the idea X causes
Y so even manipulate X it will change Y
and the way it changes you can learn it
from the data you change it according to
the regression strength but of course it
could also be a good prediction to say
the mean of Y is my best prediction
because if the underlying truth would be
that Y would cause X you manipulate X
nothing happens to Y and the best
prediction is to mean this is a very
simple problem but actually a very hard
problem to solve in practice so actually
what do you know what we want to do is
to say ok please decide make the correct
prediction whether it's here or D well
how'd you rate your simulation could you
see how did you write your simulation
could the simulation was X causes Y
let's say no I took up I married
Gaussian feed at the best straight line
you can do whatever you want to do ok I
don't know the truth
but this is actually not only synthetic
this is real so he's an exposure to a
real application in genomics it's
exactly this problem and actually it
looks very much like the synthetic data
a bit at least so here are gene
expressions here is an X gene here's a
white gene you measure thousands of
genes and what you observe are the data
points in the blue part so this is what
you observe and you can fit the
regression line well it's hard to see
that there's a regression strength
there's a correlation between these G
and B to observe then you actually do
the experiment in the lab this has been
done you manipulate the X gene it
actually had a huge effect so you kind
of turn off the activity of the X gene
and lo and behold the prediction what
came out in the experiment on the y gene
was down there which fits quite well to
this straight line and here is another
two pair of jeans so here's an X gene a
Y gene you see the observed data you see
a correlation there's a regression
strings you manipulate in the lab your
knock out the X gene there is a change
so you really have no expression of Y X
gene anymore nothing happens miss
technology it's exactly as before and
the challenge is the same how the heck
can you make the prediction whether it
should be down there or you so how do we
do this so this is in a nutshell again
the problem and of course if you only
would have these two variables in the
game it's hopeless
unless you make very very strong
assumptions on your binary distribution
the point is you have more into these
two variables and the idea may be a bit
as usual in statistics you try to borrow
strengths right but the power of
strengths is not like some sort of a
smoothing or something like that the
borough's strengths is you try to borrow
strengths from other perturbations so I
have some sort of knocked out the other
genes and from the other gene knockouts
I can try to learn that what I want to
point out very clearly if you just know
the probability distribution of the
system in a steady state if you just
have the observational distribution you
cannot solve this problem and that means
in a way if you have the best regression
or classification technology if you have
the super good
your neck you cannot solve this problem
the problem is about directionality and
a deep neural net doesn't give you an
answer and direction so as I said we
want to borrow strengths from other
perturbations so and I assume now I do
have other perturbations or maybe much
more on specific I do have heterogeneity
in my dataset so it's I kind of have
outliers but the our lives are actually
very informative I have the meditators
of course many people have worked on
causal inference there was a potential
outcome model name and was here at
Berkeley made very very fundamental and
early contribution in his master's
thesis before he came to Berkeley
there were graphical and structural
equation models Perl many others many
people at work to this we proposed
something rather different so there as
you will see there will be many so I
need to make models on the heterogeneity
and there can be fairly different ways
of models and heterogeneity so in my
gene example this the overlap I don't
need I can really have
you don't you don't see it exactly so
under additional assumptions you can try
to just predict the counterfactual so
this is what you try to do maybe we
should put that a bit offline but of
course the art is here to predict the
counterfactual and if I have predicted
this quite well I can for example mirror
and the question is how do we we need a
model and I'll develop some models here
and that is kind of in a way the art of
the game maybe bit differently to what
people have been doing before also is
that the perturbations the
heterogeneities can be rather unspecific
but the more specifically make them the
more we can say about it the more we
understand what's happening but even if
they're rather on specific you can still
do something so let's go a bit into that
so I try to formalize this a bit so
let's just think we have heterogeneous
data I don't quite know what the
heterogeneity is are how they arise but
I observed them I have known
subpopulations in the data or
experimental conditions or environments
so maybe people in Sciences do
experiments under different
environmental conditions and and so I
know this is environment one environment
- I know these environments I'm thinking
of a regression or classification type
problem and a coherence I have response
they have a distribution and all this
depends on the environment on the sub
population in your data
but if little E is the index for the
environment and this is an important
notation they are from this script E and
script E is the space of observed
environments which I have in my dataset
so let's make it very simple so the
first little simple example is I have
data from 10 different countries I have
10 different subpopulations
and so this script D this is the space
observe subpopulations it could be
labeled by 1 to up to 10 okay
so it could also be saying an economic
type context you have data from
different economical scenarios over time
and maybe your environments or your
heterogeneity has been generated over
time and so you little a typically would
be constructed as blocks of consecutive
time points the script D has been
observed in the data well I'm asking ok
now let's look at a space script F which
is much larger than script e so script
if contains the perturbations the
environments the subpopulations which I
have not observed in the data and so the
example from before script death could
be the ten countries which I have in a
date there may be all other countries in
the world which I have not seen or in
the economical prediction scenario the
script F could be the script D are the
environments the time regimes have seen
until today and script F are many many
possible perturbations environments
which might happen in the future ok you
don't see them so here is the prediction
problem it's very pragmatic I try to
predict Y given X as usual such that the
prediction works well or is robust for
all these many possible environments e
in this much larger space script if
based on data from script Eve from much
fewer environments yeah machine learning
what you're doing is from the problem of
domain adaptation it is it is a form of
transparent but it's it it's the cause
it's a coral form of transfer learning
and you'll see our models but it is a
way how to model the transfer
the alien is the prediction problem I
repeat that predict Y given X such the
prediction works well is robust for all
these many scenarios in the script F
which I have not seen in the data
okay let's mathematize dissipate and
let's look at a linear model and I look
at the l2 risk and I look at the worst
case l to risk the maximum over all
these scenarios in this future script F
and try to minimize that try to optimize
it would say this is robustness right if
you look at this problem I would also
say this some sort of a robustness
problem and now loosely speaking and I
will be founded a bit more causality is
predicting an answer to a what would
happen to a what if I perturb question
it is a prediction for a new unseen
scenario and so this is not only
robustness
I mean loosely speaking this also has
something to do about causality because
causality is kind of a framework where
you really try to predict what would
happen on an unknown scenario
in fact this is a result which you can
make rigorous and I'll come a bit more
to that but as a pre announcement you
can look at a certain space script if
now I'm talking about models for my
perturbations models for my environments
and if this script if are all
perturbations this is it loosely I'll
define it later
I'll come vas all perturbations not
acting on Y directly or needs to define
what it is then the solution of this
worst-case risk optimization problem is
the so called causal solution and that
needs to be defined as well in one the
government giving more money for public
[Music]
do the right thing so this whole
machinery does have the same beta if you
condition on the right variables if you
only include the causal variables I'll
come to that then yes then it is the
same sort of beta but if you have
different covariance you have different
shift of your covariance you just
compute the regression coefficients it
depends on how your career it's are
shifted right and then all of a sudden
if you simply compute the DRLs for
example you see very different
regression coefficients one of them it
may be itself or something now this well
it's more this kind of picture there's a
maybe it comes from Iran and me it has
influence on exit shifts my exit scales
damnit perturb them a lot and eggs of
course people then later come is much
more complicated models and I've come
with to that or maybe there's a hitman
confound er and so on so forth out I'll
discuss that but for simplicity for
simplicity at the moment you can think
of okay happy environments they change
my ex a lot this is kind of not acting
on why directly they don't know act
directly on why and now of course if I
compute regression coefficients they
will be very different so the point of
this slide is in a way to say indeed
causal parameters they do solve a worst
case risk optimization problem if you
look at a certain class and if this
class satisfy certain conditions so the
perturbation can be arbitrarily strong
but they're not allowed to activate when
you get the same
so you're asking me they're made that it
is not directly acting on why or not
yeah this is the big question
I will relax that assumption but I try
to make it a bit more easy to step in
later we will actually allow that he
points to why so I will relax it so in
my economical scenario example I would
doubt it in the genomic example there I
actually perturb the gene it probably
does not act directly on the growth rate
of the plant so this so later we will
discuss other models for script if
indeed make populations more precise so
how can we try to exploit these
heterogeneous janetti's from the data
and this is maybe a bit Hugh remarked
clear boss
so here is a conceptual and solution and
you can question that as well and we
will relax it also but conceptually I
think it's interesting to think this way
and so this is an invariant assumption
it is an assumption and I'll discuss
later when this assumption holds and the
assumption reads as follows I have an
invariant assumption with respect to
this script it is environments which
I've observed in the data and the
assumption says there exists a subset of
covariance a star is a subset of the
covalent indices such that if you
condition Y on these subsets of
covariance so this conditional
distribution then this remains invariant
across all heterogeneities across all
perturbations in this way this is just a
relaxation we have fun and but causal
people talk about the same stuff which
is kind of interesting
so this is the purpose may be a bit of
my talk trying to link the things
together you know much more about the
transfer learning than I do but it is
very close
so in a linear model setting it just
translates to okay the conditional
distribution would see be there exists a
regression parameter gamma star it's the
same gamma star be supported a star such
that you can always write ye is XE same
gamma star plus error term the error
term is uncorrelated from a star and the
residual term the error term has the
same distribution XE be discussed up
before they can shift a lot for
different perturbation theory models so
from an applied point of view and from a
transfer learning point of view we would
say okay gamma star a star is
interesting if you have a date to sit
and all of a sudden you condition on
some of the variables and then you see
it's the same recreation problem that
it's the same residual term this is
interesting right this is actually what
my collaborators in experimental science
do right they they run experiments on
different conditions that if they see a
structure which remains stable across
different environments it's an
interesting structure you know you can
ask this condition of course with
respect to another space to my script if
I mean mathematically I just ask it for
the largest space there exists a set of
arrows a star such that the conditional
distribution is invariant for this much
larger space of course we need some sort
of an assumption to make this
extrapolation otherwise it's hopeless
now this is maybe even more interesting
they say they star because it says
something about new unseen environments
and from a robustness viewpoint you can
look at it as follows you can say any
subsidy a star which fulfills the
variance assumption is interesting as it
is stabilizing the conditional
distribution and he leads to something
products and is stabilizing with
invariants will be beta to be the basis
of our robust defiant procedure what
does that has to do this causality so
some of you might know a bit of
causality some of you not hear their
various definitions of causality here is
a very simple one with structural
equation models and corresponding graphs
and influence diagrams
you have a y-variable you have an
underlying true causal influence diagram
and people would define the core
available that why are the parental
variables here in the graph if there is
a quantitative model for this graph and
this is a structural equation model so
why would just be a function of the
parental variables only comma error term
and all the x's are functions of the
parental variables comma error terms and
an important assumption is these error
terms they're mutually independent that
excludes for the moment even confounders
I'll come to that okay so my problem
what I want to look at is under what
model for the environment under model
for the perturbation how many didn't
need to talk about models for the
perturbations model for the environment
under what model do we have an
interesting description of these sets of
coherence which need two environments
and here is one interesting description
I think so loosely speaking I assume
that these perturbations do not act
directly and why if you think in terms
of graphical models my environments
would be outcomes of this variable E and
it would mean that he doesn't point
directly to Y and also the other main
assumption in causality
I guess all same transfer learning is
the perturbations do not change the
relation between x and y and hopefully
these perturbations change the
distribution of x alot because that is
informative and so typically we write it
this way
and then it's very easy to derive the
following result that we have a
structural equation model for YX we have
a model for the perturbations
so my perturbations are script if the
assumptions on my perturbations are the
ones from before they do not act
directly on Y so this is forbidden they
do not change the mechanism between x
and y and then the causal variables the
parental variable in this structural
equation model they do satisfy that
scene is structural equation model is
dynamic right it propagates through so
you will intervene on X dependence
there's dependence but no direct
dependence
now the coral variables if you condition
of them they lead to invariants under
these assumptions on these model for the
perturbation like the do perturbations
from Pearl to satisfies this model this
is a model a two pearls do operation is
a model for a perturbation and it
satisfies dissolution so if you get
invariance then it's an easy step to
show that the solution of this verse
okay drink optimization problem is the
causal parameter because intuitively if
you have verb any kind of perturbation
in this model and if you condition on
the causal variables you have invariance
so that's good that will not throw up
everything and then it's an easy step to
show that this class is sufficiently
large over which I there will be other
perturbation models I so like the
instrumental variable regression model
in economics is another perturbation
model
right nesting hub with the invariance
laid-back ethos
I'll come into the slide so they can be
are you asking me this is the only model
for the pain you I've asked you how this
model would correspond to strong ignore
ability to identify ability is another
issue here so passivity coral sets are
some sets right which satisfy invariant
but there are other sets which
satisfying variants as well now if if
the perturbation class is sufficiently
rich and this is kind of hidden in this
year too
this is all perturbations which do not
act directly on why then you can
identify okay intuitively it means the
more heterogeneities actually I see it's
kind of obvious right the more anything
if the perturbations are not arbitrarily
strong for example then the solution
will be different so we discussed it a
bit before but let's look at this again
so about these assumptions that is my
example with the growth rate of the
plant and the genomics why is the growth
rate XR very high-dimensional covariance
of gene expressions and the
perturbations are different gene
knockout perturbations and we asked
about these assumptions and it's
plausible that the first assumption
holds right if I knock out a gene it
probably does not directly influence the
growth rate of the plant that's possible
I have no clue and probably there is
something happening if I knock out the
gene I need a mechanism between x and y
changes but you need to make some sort
of first order or zero order assumption
in order to do that extrapolation
otherwise it's ovals obviously if I
knock out the gene and you can observe
that the gene expression of that knocked
out genes and a couple others no no but
I mean the assumption is that if you
knock out I knock on the gene I knock
out on the gene of course the first
equation somewhere it is a dynamic
propagation of that but the gene
knockout you really from biotechnology
you change this kind of gene you can
have put in different DNA seats and try
to block it and so that so the
biotechnological operation it's
plausible that that doesn't change
directly the growth rate of the plant
maybe it does I mean but but of course
I'm only thinking I think this is a
plausible assumption it's
is implicit there is an all other
variable are kept constant when you say
that they did the direct effect so say
that in my tongue we just argued that
causality had something to do with
invariance and he's actually very long
understood here's a picture of trick
muhabba mo he was a norwegian economist
he was very famous he got the Nobel
Prize and in 1943 already he had in his
paper that if you condition on the cold
variables he had kind of a structural
equation model he actually wrote down
there was invariance of the system and
so many people have worked on that if
you condition on the cold variables you
get invariance
now the interesting other direction is
if you actually see invariance in the
date and maybe you can try to do that
you have maybe a lot of data and you can
try to infer invariants in the data for
C invariant in the data can you conclude
on causality or on some sort of
predictive stability and the answer is
yes you can do something and so this is
kind of the pursuit of search for
invariants in the data and try to
conclude on causal structures or get
predictive robustness now for the
experts in the room there's the severan
identifiability issues this was a
question to be there so you cannot in
general you can only get the mark of
equivalence class of the graphs and I'm
skipping many details here because I
want to come more to the robustness
story but what you can do is you can
come up with at least a conservative
procedure which has a type 1 guarantee
against false positive selection so it's
kind of a formula but with controllable
probability under these assumptions on
the perturbation model and you have a
structural equation model you can come
up with an algorithm which with high
probability would not produce a false
causal solution
maybe it doesn't find anything if you
pointed that out earlier maybe these
algorithms just spit out I don't find
any portal here too bad but when it
finds something other these conditions
controllable probability it must be a
correlative so here is a framework which
is much more quantitative and keeps kind
of a clearer understanding maybe also
how we can relax the conditions and what
the corresponding robustness is and we
call this anchor regression and there's
a core a corresponding causal
regularization and I'm doing a slight
sneak switch in notation so my
environments from before there now
outcomes of what we call an anchor but
it is an A instead of an e and the
picture is the same as here so have
environments I have outcomes of this
anchor variable they might influence X
and then the propagation is from X to Y
I'm just looking at linear systems I
looking at linear structural equation
models and this would be doable so
they're much more celebrated novelist
instrumental variable regression model
and this is very relevant now you say ok
you have hidden confounding variables
that of course happens always in real
life and this is the model the main
assumption in this model is that people
call is an instrument the instrument
does not have an effect on H on the
hidden confounders and the instrument
also again the same assumption from
before the instrument does not have a
direct effect on Y and I'm not an
economist but at least from my more
maybe biology dream and applications
this seems to be difficult how the heck
can I find an instrument which has no
effect on hidden structure and I cannot
even name what the hidden structure is
right
so we want to relax that assumption they
say ok this instrument this anchor is
allowed to point to H Heaton structure I
don't know what it is it can be very
multivariate the anchor can also point
to why I relax that assumption it can
have a direct effect on Y so you asked
for this before this is possible there
can also be cyclic structure here for
the simple as for simplicity I look at
linear systems
the only assumption here is the anchor
is why it's called an anchor it's a
source node in the graph and people in
economics would call it an exogenous
variable so the anchor is an exogenous
variable and so here's my linear
structural equation model there's a
near-term and exogenous term which comes
from these anchors so the environments
this is an exogenous term which comes
into the system instrumental variable
regression is a special case of anchor
we relax this very stringent condition
but there is of course a price to be
paid for that and that's probably why
many people have not looked at this
there's now a fundamental
identifiability problem if your
instrument if your anchor points to H or
and to Y you cannot identify the causal
effect it's impossible people said well
this is a new post model e they field
post for causality but you still get
some sort of robustness properties with
this model and we think this is
interesting so this is what I just said
this what we call call regularization
can offer something in this model and
what you can prove this is non-trivial
but you can still achieve a form of
invariance we call it a shifty means
I'll define it and what it's a
non-trivial factor show is that you
still get shift invariance so residuals
are so-called invariant under shift
perturbations if and only if the
residuals are uncorrelated with your
anchor variable this your instrument
otherwise it's a uncorrelated this
becomes dependent it's harder but
conceptually it's the same but actually
doing it in practice is much harder it
becomes to conditional independence
testing and errors
so but in a linear pace what we didn't
try to do is to encourage orthogonality
of the residuals with a so you construct
an estimator like you minimize residual
sum of squares and we encourage the
solution which is fairly or talk not to
a so exciti regularization parameter for
large try move it to solution running
out of time
this is a bit a different way to express
that estimator it's just written down
these projections on a this is very
similar of course the PI is the
protection on the column space of a and
so the anchor regression estimator is
solving this optimization problem
project so this is the anti projection
of the residual length squared plus
gamma regularization term projection on
a residual length script for gamma
leaking one you have least squares
because you can obviously compose the
squared error into anti projection of
projection where for general gaana gamma
it's a regularization
it's a convex problem it's very easy to
solve if you're in high dimensions you
can add one penalty's group sparsity
penalties and so on so there's a
fundamental identifiability problem but
these anchor regression estimator solves
for optimizing Everest K's risk so it
has a robustness property and give me a
bit time to introduce that so here is
the shift perturbation this is the class
of perturbations so the model for the
heterogeneous data is this linear system
there's the exogenous term and the
perturbed version is replacing the
heterogeneity with a shift victory can
be deterministic it can be random it's
this V here so this is the shifted
version it's dynamic and the B has a
certain while this is a technical
definition it's in the span of him but
it has a certain length gamma a certain
size gamma gamma large is a large shift
gammas Melissa's motion and this is
maybe an interesting theorem it can
prove that in the population version and
in for the sample version you can give
bounds on that but a population version
there's a very interesting duality so PA
is now the population version of the
projection is the conditional
expectation and the theorem says for any
regression parameter you look at the
worst-case risk in this shift
perturbation class the shifts in this
class have a certain strength a certain
size gamma and this gamma and it
the regularization term here so this is
the population version of my aunt
regression estimator it's anti
protection receiver Ling squared plus
gamma regularization of the projection
of the residual industry it is a very
interesting connection we think between
shift perturbations kind of causality
causality will be all perturbations this
is on a subclass and robustness and of
course because you have this this holds
also for the aardman this is the
justification that is an correlation
actually doesn't make me the causal
solution but it gives you a more causal
appeared solution which is robust
against graduations you can apply this
in practice you can look at a couple of
real data analysis and you can look at
performance in terms of robustness in
terms of prediction gain and if you
apply that on larger scale data rarely
expected virginity you do gain over the
standard machinery with least squares
that it was at least for example it's
about the impact and in artists in games
is an example where you can use random
forests this is the nonlinear version
you have no theory on this but we have
an algorithm you can stick in around a
forest you can stick it another machine
learning technique and if the data is
hater genius and if the future will be a
bit different that's the transfer
learning aspect
and so I always have been taught that
you know heterogeneity is some sort of
bad thing non-stationarity is not good
here is somehow a story where you try to
exploit it it's informative and you
better make it your friend rather than
you it's like a way commercial or a
square at your stage of discord
so what we noticed if the IP model is
correct then the second one to say this
word will give you the crack bouncer but
audio this square will give you very
much about rights from but here you make
Romanian version so that means in if the
model is correct
so eating the Ivy model if it's correct
it can to two-stage least fears if you
use it on real data as you might know it
as a huge variance two stage least
squares so one finite sample actually if
you regular eyes and Duma paid
regularization you improve over the
standard two stage least squares
estimator but the point is the designer
regression estimator if I choose gamma
equals affinity I get the two stage
least square estimator in Div model the
other point is that if the IV
assumptions actually hold if the
instruments are valid and so on toe
force which design correlation estimated
miss comma infinity I get the causal
solution
okay that's thanks people again a short
break